first three launches of falcon didn't
work then the fourth one we scraped
together some parts and
then that one worked and if that one
hadn't worked it would have been that
would have been it for us
i think having some self-confidence uh
is different than finding your passion i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it's just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
i believe hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some insights from
elon musk
bill gates and other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one get comfortable with failures
with elon musk
i always thought we would fail so this
is uh oh it's all upside
down you know i thought maybe we had a
10 chance of reaching orbit
starting out so then uh
if people thought when we started spacex
they said oh you're gonna fail
uh so i agree i think we probably will
fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this this i said i'd lose
like you know lose all the money from
paypal i was like well you're probably
right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches of falcon didn't work
and the fourth one we scraped together
some parts and then that one worked and
if that one hadn't worked
would have been that would have been it
for us so um
i really believe in the future of space
and and i think it's important that we
become a space frank civilization and
and not be out there among the stars and
i think that's one of the things that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction novels
and movies not to be science fiction
forever we want to be real one day
lesson number two have self-confidence
with bill gates
i think having some self-confidence
is different than finding your passion
from a young age ideally you'll have
adults in your life preferably your
parents
as part of that some of your teachers
people around you who
who like you and they're behind you and
they'll back you
no matter what goes on and that gives
you enough confidence to go off on a
quest
and during that quest you try different
things out if you're lucky when you're
very young you find something you're
passionate about
i did when i was 13 years old i found
computers and software
took me another five years to figure out
that was my
life's uh primary work but that's a
lucky thing
other people you know get out into their
twenties or even later before they find
uh what they're passionate about but
proceeding with a certain set of
self-confidence that there are people
who care for you you care for them
that you succeed in their eyes by your
uh
uh how you treat them i think that's
that's pretty basic and it gives you the
platform
on which to try out new things to fail
you know at first you're not going to
succeed in in various things so
self-confidence is primary and then
finding your passion
is a an adventure request that that may
take time and it may switch
over the time time of your life but
those deep relationships will let you
uh pursue it with bigger lesson number
three read
biographies with warren buffett i should
mention one thing about reading
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than any other
uh student i i lived there practically
but you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
because of that librarian directing me
to some other book and then following
through on that
it's the chance i i i read about
one-fifth the pace the bill does but i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people that have been
seeing so extraordinary the lessons and
the you know the discouragements they
face just everything about it so i did
you can't get enough of reading lesson
number four collaborate with grant
cardone
the fastest way to grow a business is to
collaborate with other people
is to find uh these fairies that are
going back and forth b-roll
okay uh the fairies uh dude i mean i
could build a boat
or i could just go wrong on one of those
exactly right and
what what we're doing today is we are
drafting or just collaborating with
yeah um cardone capital
i don't go build apartments no i buy
apartments that are already built
that way i can scale faster if i was
trying to do the building thing now now
construction teams right um
now along the way i'm fixing i'm
adjusting as i go
okay but but i need to get in the water
and start swimming
in some direction i think too many
people are trying to figure out where
they're going yeah
and by the time you figure it out
somebody's already there hey man
everybody how you doing buddy
good how are you you got a book coming
out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five be brutally honest with
yourself
with mark cuban even after you had done
your thing
there was still an eighth course to make
sure that
yahoo itself was on track do you know
what that was about yeah they were
screwing everything up
you know i mean look they had they had
an opportunity to dominate
um streaming media they also own at the
same time
the patent to cost per click yeah right
now
google's entire business to this day is
built around
pay-per-click rather than pay-per-click
yeah so they had the entire
patent for pay-per-click had they just
said
sorry google you can't use it there
would be no google
instead they said yeah 133 million
dollars and give us some stock
they were just too nice right which
blinded them in a lot of respects and
i remember walking in with a 32 million
dollar sale
saying okay we're going to do streaming
we're going to sell all this company's
content
you know it's worth 32 million dollars
for us and it's going to pre-up
these other potential competitors and
um i forget if it's jerry or tim whoever
said no
we don't work that way we don't preempt
competition we just leave it open
i'm like okay it's time for me to go buy
a basketball team
that's they just they just didn't see
these things and i mean it's a lesson in
your businesses there's going to be
everybody's always trying to kick your
ass and you have to figure out how to
kick your out your own ass first
seriously because if you're not brutally
honest with yourself and your own
business
about what your frailties are someone
else is going to find them
yahoo didn't get that yahoo just thought
you know what we're just going to
continue moving forward and we'll just
compete
with everybody else and you know there's
we have no other problems
it didn't quite work out for them did it
no lesson number six learn
from the experience with jamie curran
lima i was paying my way through school
and i was working as a waitress at
denny's
and it was a challenging denny's and so
what i mean by that is
they had problems getting pancakes out
and people get so frustrated
so it would take an hour sometimes to
get your meal so i would talk and try to
like
you know learn the customer stories yeah
i would you know anything you didn't
have to ring up like the ice cream i
would
i would offer ice cream whatever anyways
i got fired for talking too much
yeah yeah from denny's but it was a
blessing to go through right because i
learned a lot too and i was like okay
trying to understand i didn't know at
the time i'd be an entrepreneur later
trying to also make sure i figured out
operations so even when you're sitting
there inside of a kitchen
going why is it taking 45 minutes to get
pancakes and what's the ordering process
and the back end of the operations
it's all a gift like everything we go
through can be that way
um and if we have the mindset where we
go okay what can i learn from this
experience and what can i take out of it
and
and learn from it and lesson number
seven the last one before very special
bonus clip
is help others with oprah winfrey i have
a very big
life and so people with big lives can do
big things and so i started to think
about
what was the best christmas i ever had
in my life
i grew up poor uh on welfare with my
mother for part of my life
and i remember that the best christmas
of my life was when i was 12 years
old and my mother had said we're not
going to have christmas
because we can't afford it and my
feeling at the time was okay well
so that runs that's santa claus bit i
was 12 that's when i realized there was
no santa claus because now he ain't
coming because we're poor
and uh i remember feeling like
it's going to be really hard on
christmas morning
to go outside everybody had you know you
go outside with your toys
what am i going to do when everybody
else is outside
that's what i thought what am i going to
do when everybody else is outside and
what am i going to do when i have to go
back to class
and say i got nothing so that's what i
was mostly worried about
and then some nuns showed up some three
nuns came to our house and they gave me
a doll and they bought us food
and we had our christmas that was the
best christmas of my life
because somebody remembered and i wasn't
going to have to be
the kid that said i got nothing so i
wanted to be able to create that same
feeling
for children who had nothing so i
decided to go to south africa originally
i wanted to do a million kids because i
thought we can do a million kids
and then just realize with i only had uh
four weeks vacation so in four weeks i
could not reach a million kids because i
didn't want to just write a check
send a donation i wanted to be able to
look in each kid's face and say to that
child
somebody remembered you and so that's
what i did
with my life this christmas i took 41
people from here
hired another 50 people over there and
we were
traveling caravan from one village to
the next we did 2
000 kids a day we had
parties for children who were orphans
and it was singularly i will tell you i
could weep thinking about it
the singularly the best experience of
my life the singularly
best experience of my life the first day
in africa
where we had um three
280 kids in a room and every single one
of those kids had lost a parent
every single one of those children they
were aged three
to 17 in that room and my team
that you're talking about i have the
greatest team in the world my team
in the here in the united states had
been in contact with the orphanages so
that by the time we got there
we had a present with every child's name
on it
i had um uh
this summer every black doll
manufacturer in the country had sent me
dolls because i
these girls had never seen black dolls
and so it was my mission
to do for them what the nuns had done
for me was to let the
african girl see a black doll so i
wanted every girl to have a black doll i
wanted every boy to have
soccer balls we bought radios we bought
clothes
and the most important thing is we had
their names on every box for every child
and i called up the children one by one
and when those
children you know received their gifts
and then waited for the next child to
receive their gifts
and said i said nobody can open their
presents
until everybody can open their presents
and on the count of three when i counted
the three and those children
open their presents was the single
greatest
moment of my life and i share that with
you
i share that with you because
that's what i can do i can be i have a
big life so i can take 50 000 presents
and do that over and over and over again
to orphanage
effort orphanage but what i felt in that
room for those from those kids
is a lot of what you're talking about
and what you're talking about and what
you see in the faces of those women
when you look into the eyes of someone
and you
give them a gift whether that be a
physical gift or it'd be
a gift from your spiritual self
from your presence from the essence of
you and you see the light you see the
joy
what i felt in that room was not just
that i was remembered
that that the child felt that i was
remembered but you
felt a sense of hope a sense of
validation
a sense of validation that somebody
cared about
me and i will tell you that of
all the years and shows that i have done
and every theme for every show that i've
done the single common denominator
denominator that i found that
every human being is looking for is
validation
every single person needs to know
wants to feel that they matter that they
matter
and what happened in that room that was
the greatest day of my life
i knew that those children knew in that
moment
that they mattered that they mattered
and so i
encourage you it's exciting to be able
to write a check
it's even more exciting to be able to
touch
one life to be able to do that for
one person it's like cynthia was saying
when you can do that for one
person when you can do that you will
know that your life
has meaning and i will tell you when i
left that place my friend gail and i
were there and we're all boohoo and
we're like booming with the children oh
my god
and gail was saying what is it what is
it we're so full as gail said to me she
said you know as big as your show is
as big as your show is what happened in
that room
seemed bigger what happened in that room
sing bigger
and that is true that is true for me who
has this big life in a television show
and i'm telling you for everybody here
extending yourself beyond your world
your kids your family your stuff and
reaching out to somebody who is
not like you somebody who is like you
who
is indeed if you are feeling depressed
or you are feeling down or you're
feeling like things aren't going the way
you want them to go in your life
the way you turn that around is to reach
outside of yourself
to somebody else reach outside of
yourself to somebody else
it will change you
it will change you now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place and how you're
going to actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you one part that i'm always um
very focused on sort of the structure of
these companies and how
how well are people aligned and so you
can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal
kind of a framework to think about what
are people's incentives
you know are they going to be aligned or
not and i think you want to both have
formal alignment where you set the
structure right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to
work together well in one one way or
another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um
you know there's always a there's always
a uh there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders
of companies which is um how did you
uh how did you meet
what's the pre-history of the company
before you got started
i find that to be really instructive a
set of questions to ask
a bad answer is something like you know
we met
a week ago at a social networking
function at a business networking
function we decided to start a company
because we both wanted to be
entrepreneurs um
you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas
and you might hit the jackpot but it's
probably a really bad idea
um and a much better answer is you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time
you know maybe one of us is more on the
tech side the other one's more on the
business side we have these sort of
complementary skills
and and so i think this question of
alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important
if you want even more insight into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you should just
be yourself right i mean i take pride in
the fact that i didn't give
what anybody thought or said i was just
going to be myself i find if i don't get
enough sleep then i'm i'm
quite grumpy i mean obviously i think
most people that way